boum youtube je sais on dirait que ça
fédère les gens mais on s'en fout
puisque je suis très content je suis
extrêmement content de vous annoncer
officiellement enfin la date de mon
premier meetup j'avais annoncé il ya
quelques mois car 50 mille abonnés on
ferait un meet up on a passé cinquante
mille et très rapidement les 100000 donc
ça devient le meet up des cinquante
mille cent mille on sait plus trop
depuis plusieurs semaines je cherchais
le lieu où on allait faire dans paris
donc je comptais privatiser un endroit
le lieu et puis après sur place vous
auriez payé vos boissons repas ce genre
de choses eh bien j'ai une bien
meilleure nouvelle que ça eh bien j'ai
bien meilleure nouvelle que ça puisque
le youtube space paris m'a proposé
d'organiser le meet up chez eux dans
leurs locaux qui sont eux mêmes dans les
locaux de google france
si vous suivez bien la chaîne vous avez
déjà compris que ce serait le 2 octobre
donc ce sera bien le 2 octobre prochain
de 18h à 20h30 au youtube space paris
qui se trouvent huit rues de londres
entre cris ni té et gare saint lazare
donc il va se passer plusieurs choisir
un espèce de talk avec deux nations est
au départ une sorte de foire aux
questions en live
oui mais afin qu ça veut pas dire fois
en question oui mais quand on peut dire
quand même foire aux questions si on a
envie je pense bien en profiter pour
vous mentaliser un petit peu et filmé
tout ça aussi pour la chaîne pour ceux
qui pourront pas venir soit parce qu'ils
sont pas à paris soit parce qu'ils sont
pas disponibles on n'oubliera pas tout
le reste de la team menthe à l'eau quand
même et puis après on aura une heure et
demie deux heures pour se rencontrer
discuter boire des coups ensemble
puisque c'est youtube qui nous offrent
toutes les consommations il prévoit tout
sur place et en ça c'est super cool
merci à eux merci pour moi mais surtout
merci pour vous en fait parce que perso
j'aurais pas pu vous inviter pour tout
ce qui est des consoles voilà je suis
ravi de ça et vous voulez peut-être la
procédure ou alors venir je vous mets un
lien dans la description vous cliquez
sur ce lien si un formulaire de chez
youtube vous vous inscrivez dessus ça
fonctionne sur la règle du premier
arrivé premier servi
vous vous inscrivez vous avez un petit
mail de confirmation comme quoi vous
êtes pré inscrits à l'événement et dans
quelques jours youtube vous confirmera
que tout est ok parce qu'on va vérifier
qu'un parent les personnes peuvent bien
venir
l'histoire qui est pas une place vacante
alors que quelqu'un aurait pu venir
premier arrivé premier servi ça veut
dire aussi que ça part vite puisqu'il
n'ya qu'une centaine de places mais en
même temps tout le monde n'est pas
disponible 12 octobre tout le monde ne
va pas voir cette vidéo dès samedi matin
à 11 heures tout le monde n'habite pas
paris on n'a pas forcément la
possibilité d'être à paris le 2 octobre
donc si vous pouvez venir si vous voulez
venir n'hésitez pas je ne sais pas si ça
se voit mais je suis très excité et très
heureux que ça se passe enfin et qu'on
se rencontre réellement il y aura
d'autres meetup ailleurs en france au
fur et à mesure des mois qui viennent
le meilleur moyen de se rencontrer et on
l'a vu juste là le 23 septembre à la
garenne-colombes c'était super cool
c'est si vous venez un spectacle de
m'attendre à la fin donc pour voir
toutes les dates de spectacles vous
allez sur le site www.fairesearch.de fr
il ya toutes les dates de tournée je
vous mets le lien dans la description
également sur le site vous trouverez
plein de choses dont toutes les dates de
tournée qui sont officialisés et de
temps en temps on en rajoute comme ça
c'est régulièrement des consignes dans
un autre théâtre et que je suis sûr de
venir dans une autre ville je vous le
mets ta va être cool ça va être morte et
le voir enfin se rencontrer par autre
chose qu'un écran interposé
si vous aussi vous êtes content qu'on se
voit le 12 octobre ou qu'on se voie sur
2 tours ne vous plaît est un petit pouce
en l'air si vous êtes fraîchement
arrivée sur la chaîne n'oubliez pas de
vous abonner avant de partir et
n'oubliez pas que le mental bugs et une
vidéo par jour pendant un an
du 1er janvier au 31 décembre doit être
à la 275 aujourd'hui donc rendez vous
demain à 11 heures
charles